[Música]
las últimas boletas han dejado esta
parte de islandia hace mucho tiempo pero
aquí se mantiene el recuerdo de las
aventuras de una época diferente
aquí miles de pescadores franceses
escribieron un capítulo poco conocido de
la historia marítima
venían de pueblos y ciudades costeras
como gravelinas paintball fecam y kale y
viajaban aquí para pescar bacalao del
cual hay mucho en estas frías aguas
durante cuatro siglos y hasta 1935 los
pescadores se detenían aquí en este
pueblo del este de islandia un lugar que
ahora se conoce como el pequeño pueblo
francés entre los lugareños
mi abuelo solía ser muy feliz cuando los
pescadores venían aquí al fiordo tenían
galletas coñac y vino tinto
y a cambio mi abuela les daba suéteres y
calcetines islandeses
todos estaban muy contentos se
despidieron
recuerdos alegres aunque la realidad era
muy diferente especialmente para los
marineros pasaban ocho meses sin el mal
trabajando 24 horas al día mientras se
enfrentaban a la posibilidad de
enfermedades congelaciones hundimientos
y nostalgia se cree que entre 4 y 5 mil
marineros murieron muchos de ellos
perdidos en el mar pero algunos yacen en
el cementerio del pequeño pueblo los
pescadores también construyeron un
hospital en el pueblo el primero en
islandia el edificio es ahora un museo
un tributo a aquellos que lo hicieron
posible
festivales a los pescadores están
esperando para ver un médico mira este
joven debe tener 12 o 13 años
siempre había un joven a bordo
hacia café y limpiaba
[Música]
estos niños tienen justo la misma edad
pero un día serán los responsables de
mantener vivo el recuerdo de estos
hombres
claro
aprenden sobre esta historia vivieran
aquí cada primavera a visitar este museo
todo el mundo en este pueblo quiere
hacer visible esta historia casi todos
los años hombres y mujeres franceses
algunos de ellos descendientes de los
pescadores vienen aquí para saber más
sobre aquellos que alimentaron a su país
a un costo tan grande si todos vienen de
nuestra ciudad natal el pueblo también
se ha convertido en un destino turístico
esta pareja parisina está viajando a lo
largo de la costa de islandia pero nunca
había oído hablar de la historia de este
pueblo hasta que llegaron aquí
no teníamos ni idea de la historia local
y de la conexión con francia si existe
nos enteramos cuando llegamos ayer aquí
cuando vimos los carteles que señalaban
a francia cuando vimos el museo y es
fascinante ver la interacción entre los
dos países
fue muy interesante a lo largo de la
primera guerra mundial el número de
naves francesas que se detuvieron aquí
comenzó a disminuir en 1935 el último
barco se fue y nunca regresó
islandia había comenzado a proteger sus
aguas territoriales y las tripulaciones
francesas ya estaban hartas de estos
viajes peligrosos y a veces mortales